The LCD would be x squared times x plus 2. Remember we want the highest power of
any factor that appears in a denominator. So we know x is already a factor of x
squared, so we should use x squared. And X plus two for our LCD. Another way to
think about this, is to use our factor tree method to find the LCD of X squared
and X plus two. We use X squared here, since we know X is already a factor of X
squared. Now don't make the mistake of putting X as the common factor here. X
plus two is one factor. Wgereas X squared has the factors of X and X. The only
common factor for X squared and the quantity X plus two is one. This also makes
sense because this X is a term inside this factor. So our LCD is X squared times
one times the quantity X plus two.